So let’s take a look at our Jersey Square team as
an example and see how they came up with their
value proposition. Now, what’s interesting is if
you remember value proposition describes not
only the features but also the pains and gains
that they see, that they’ve actually craved for the
customer and that the goal is to figure out what
the MVP is.
And if we see the Jersey Square team,
they actually did a pretty good job talking
about pains and gains, a cheaper way to wear
officially licensed sports jerseys to a game,
to eliminate the risk of owning a player’s jersey
who is going to be traded, or to provide an
alternative to purchasing counterfeit jerseys.
Pretty good for pains and gains.
But what they forgot to describe is what are the
features and just so we could remember the
features for Jersey Square is they were going to
provide a single place where you could rent sports
jerseys, so you wouldn’t have to own them and
maintain them to visit your favorite team.
And what they also missed is what was the
MVP or minimum viable product of what they
were going to build. And in their case it was
going to be a website with rental and a stock of
jerseys of the most popular teams at first in the
New York area and then nationally in the United
States and then ultimately internationally.
So those were kind of missing, but again
starting with pains and gains was pretty
good for their value proposition.
Notice by the way, while they were working on
value proposition, they also had some
hypothesis about the customer segments.
And this is a key idea, value proposition and
customer segments are the first two things you
tend to work on with the business model canvas.
Because these two have a special name called
product market fit. And product market fit just
simply says what is the match between what you
are building and what customers need and
want, and who are those customers.
So, while the goal in value prop is to figure out
the MVP, yes, we’ll see later the goal in
customer segments is to figure out who and
what the archetype of the customer is. So again
you could start either with customer segments or
you could start with a product and value prop
itself, it really doesn’t matter. But in most teams
if they are technology driven, they tend to start
on value prop and most teams if they happen to
be marketers or business people, happen to start
with the customer segments. There is no right
place, but it’s the interaction between these two.